elle était victime d'insultes la part de
voyageurs elle s'est rendu à l'aéroport
de Nice quelques heures après l'énergie
Music Awards et elle s'est pris un tollé
de la part des voyageurs présents
pourquoi en fait ils n'ont pas apprécié
qu'elle emprunte un passage VIP pour
monter dans l'avion plusieurs vidéos ont
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est
vrai que ça ça fait énormément parler
les vidéos sont folles est-ce que vous
vous êtes d'accord avec avec les
voyageurs ou bien ce que vous comprenez
pas cette attitude envers Aya Nakamura
[Musique]
une autre une autre
non mais voilà alors voilà franchement
alors
franchement quoi tout simplement toutes
les tous les gens connus et même dans ce
plateau personne fait la queue à
l'aéroport
je te connais tu ne fais jamais là
vraiment tu dis n'importe quoi alors il
paraît qu'elle aurait refusé des selfies
il y en a qu'à moi mais je pense qu'ils
disent ça c'est autre chose en fait
passer par là aussi parce que ça fait
des meute
j'ai déjà pas je suis déjà passé comme
ça devant tout le monde effectivement
les gens sont pas très voilà ils sont
pas très contents voilà mais c'est pas
c'est normal que il y a un service pour
les gens connus
Mathieu Delormeau qui est pas du tout
d'accord pardon non c'est après si tu es
une star bah tu prends un jet tu fais ce
que tu veux que ton argent moi j'ai
aucun souci avec les gens qui va Josette
que voilà bien pas de problème mais
sinon je suis des mecs
non mais voilà mais sinon sinon je suis
je suis désolé elle peut avoir quelqu'un
la sécurité à côté pour pas faire trop
de selfies après les gens sont pas
débiles ils se jettent pas sur toi et
ben tu sais je sais pas easyJet ou
Transavia bah tu fais la queue comme
tout le monde et tu attends au nom de
quoi elle passe devant
incroyable et là un truc qui est
tellement évident que des gens qui font
pas la queue à l'aéroport donc faut pas
la queue à la SNCF on passe devant tout
le monde et tout mais d'où les
célébrités en prison ils ont une cellule
plutôt spéciale pareil faire agresser là
il va se faire agresser je vous le dis
j'ai vu la dernière fois Daniel il passe
droit non mais c'est vrai elle était un
guinguette Nogent-sur-Marne
elle est passée devant tout le monde
mais juste parce qu'elle marchait plus
vite que les autres euh tout simplement
oui Gilles mais pour moi pour moi Aya
Nakamura c'est une star elle ne peut pas
faire une file d'attente avec des gens
c'est impossible même pour la sécurité
même pour l'écoulement des gens c'est
impossible il y en a qu'à moi c'est
comme l'équipe de France de foot ils
vont pas attendre trois heures devant
tout le monde va y avoir des milliers ça
crée une émeute tu es con de la première
la dernière minute de mission
en plus il n'arrête pas du tout une une
queue enfin il y a pas des gens ils ne
bloque pas des gens pour la faire passer
elle a juste un passage privilégié
pour toi
alors là voilà voilà
que moi ça me va très bien je parlais de
la file d'attente
chez moi
la traque des réseaux sociaux je la
trouve très violente parce que malgré
tout elle sourit elle est oui
sympathique et là tout de suite tu t'es
d'accord avec moi personnellement j'ai
jamais coupé la queue de quoi que ce
[Rires]
un tout petit peu plus cher si on a une
validité tout ça mais sinon moi on m'a
jamais dit toi tu es gentil tu es sur
TPMP
et franchement c'est vrai moi ça va
arriver bah oui bah je suis arrivé à
l'aéroport et c'est vrai quoi il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup moi j'adore en plus
discuter tout ça et tout et en fait ça a
foutu un petit bordel
forcément
est-ce que vous pouvez passer parce que
sinon ça voilà et en fait les gens
étaient super sympas j'ai pris trois
quatre personnes avec moi que je ne
connaissais pas comme on voit tout comme
en boîte il m'a dit ils sont avec toi
ouais ouais
avec des gens que je ne connaissais pas
voilà c'est vrai tu vois mais mais je
vous dis c'est parce que si ça peut
créer des des embouteillages Aya
Nakamura
c'est quand même hyper violent alors ça
je crois que c'est parce que c'est parce
qu'elle avait refusé les selfies c'est
ce qu'on m'a dit voilà après bon voilà
après c'est vrai que moi je trouve ça en
fait selfie peut-être que le 200-zième
elle dit non stop je suis pressé toi
j'aimerais bien savoir parce que en plus
je sais que toi tu ça va
regarde-moi
ça va super mais en salle de réveil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas pouvoir être sur pied dans
combien de temps une petite semaine on
va très bien allez alors dis-moi
qu'est-ce que tu veux non moi je dis
c'est vrai quand il y a un sacré des
émeutes et que ça fout un bordel les
mecs pour faciliter leur taf ils vont
les faire ils vont la faire entrer mais
là elle rentre dans un truc accès au
personnel et tu dis il y a tu peux payer
plus cher pour pas faire l'accueil il y
a des trucs comme dans les parcs
d'attractions
[Rires]
les célébrités ne sont pas supérieures
merci
alors bah voilà et puis après
visiblement elle est pas c'est pas la
fille qui est reconnue pour être la plus
salée je ne sais pas ah tu l'adores bah
elle est très sympa c'est pas de
problème
mais c'est vrai que aujourd'hui si tu as
de l'argent il y a plein de moyens de
pas faire tu es quand même un petit peu
hypocrite parce que tu profites aussi ta
notoriété par on pour réserver une table
dans un restaurant si c'est complet tu
vas dire
voilà où tu te fais passer pour Cyril et
puis aussi donc
accélérateurs aussi de particules grâce
à ta notoriété donc non tu peux pas lui
en vouloir à elle et toi tu fais la même
chose que tu négocies parfois par
exemple des tarifs tout ça des prix mais
encore une fois c'est au détriment de
personnes et pourquoi les gens font la
queue pourquoi tu payes moins cher alors
que tu es blindé alors que quelqu'un qui
a moins d'argent que toi il va appeler
je n'enlève pas la chambre de quelqu'un
je paye moins cher ma chambre pourquoi
payer moins cher hein tu négocies
j'ai adoré
moins cher mais je paye moins cher parce
que alors ça c'est autre chose l'hôtel
est ravi de recevoir un artiste
[Musique]
tu sais que quand j'étais d'ailleurs
à Versailles je dirais pas le nom de
l'hôtel
et un peu trop grâce à Cyril parce que
du coup ils sont venus frapper à ma
porte et il y avait une petite bar
mitzvah pour son fils et il m'a demandé
si je pouvais venir faire un petit
passage pour la Barbie c'est pas vrai
oui absolument
pas hein
non non
énormément de pognon c'est mieux comme
ça je le confirme pour les gens coréens
doutes si tu veux c'est vrai que moi que
j'avais plein de pognons je vais dire tu
vas au service
des forces à Air France tu arrives on
vient de chercher en voiture tu donnes
ta valise la valise entre la merde tu
fais aucune formalité et tu passes
devant tout le monde sans que personne
ne le voit et c'est vrai que c'est
moyen
et maintenant tu peux plus faire ça ah
bah c'était dire cette triple le billet
quand même hein
si tu prends un pari Rio par exemple en
first first c'est-à-dire tu es au
restaurant du First à l'aéroport et tout
le bordel tu as reçu comme un prince
tout mais ça te coûte trois fois le prix
d'un billet normal
[Rires]
c'est vrai que les les salons privés et
tout c'est super bien et quand tu es
quand tu es toute jeune fille et que
c'est la première fois un peu petit
voyage alors les envoyer
personne
on comprend même pas la passerelle on
prend même pas la passerelle il y a une
voiture qui vous emmène en bas de
l'avion ah oui oui bien sûr vous
connaissez pas Cyril et par contre tu
montes à la corde ça c'est
on vous emmène directement on voudrait
directement directement dans un petit
salon vous avez même pas de guichet vous
allez bien vous prendre la valise on
vous emmène dans un très beau salon qui
est derrière ta femme et un psy qui
vient
plus c'est vachement organisé que et en
fait qui alors à Roissy c'est Alain
Ducasse qui est en charge oui bien sûr
et que j'avais le même truc que c'était
ma Alain du casse-toi de là vous avez
vous avez un spa vous avez vous
avez vu
le gars dans ma tata et tu imagines le
gars monsieur
[Rires]
Amazon
juste après j'arrive
dans l'avion présidentiel alors voir le
pape et ben Sarkozy il avait un lit de
de un kinsize de 2m40 sur 2 mètres 40
une vraie chambre bon et alors on va
dire pourquoi il a pas un siège normal
ben parce que président
faut faire président quoi le ministre il
a quoi il a un lit super